♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est laououvelle coqueluche
du mouvement MAGA de Donald
Trump. Kari Lake, 53 ans, est
la favorite pour le poste
de gouverneur en Arizona.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est l'Halloween, on se déguise
en mur, en combattant, mais
derrière chaque costume
un message. Sous les allures
d'une ambiance bonne enfant,
c'est un rassemblement
politique.
♪ ♪ ♪
On distribue les bonbons,
et puis on écorche au passage
Katie Hobbs, la rivale
démocrate, qui refusede débattr.
Kari Lake, c'est Dond d Trump
en talon haut disent ses
adversaires. Cette ancienne
présentatrice de Fox News, qui
parle aujourd'hui de "fake
news" est plus polissé,
mais livre le même message
anti-migrant, mur à la
frontière, anti-avortement
et ee e ne reconnaît pas non
plus les résultats des élections
de 2020.
"Il y avait définitivement de
la fraude," dit cette partisane.
"Regardez notre pays, regardez
l'inflation, le prix du gaz
dit-elle, on n'a jamais eu
ce problème avec Donald Trump."
C'est dans un climat tendu
que se déroule ces élections
de mi-mandat. Des vigiles armées
surveillent les électeurs
qui votent par anticipation.
C'est légal, a tranché un juge
fédéral nommé par Donald Trump,
après qu'il y ait plieieurs
plaintes d'intimidation.
"Êtes-vous intimid p par moi?
Dit-il, je porte une arme"
James Vaughan surveille aussi
ceux qui votent.
"C'est de la vigilance dit-il.
On est dans notre droit, on veut
s'assurer que le système est
respecté."
Et cette vigilance est
encouragée par Mark Finchem,
candidat républicain au poste
de secrétaire d'État.
Comme Kari Lake, il ne reconnait
pas les élections de 2020.
Il a maintes fois répété
qu'il n'aurait jamais certifié
le vote qui donnait la victoir
à Joe Biden.
"C'est un Oath Keeper,
un antisémite, un extrémiste
qui a appelé à la guerre
civile."
Selon Adrian Fontes, son rival
démocrate, on n'est plus dans
la partisannerie politique,
mais dans la défense de larépub.
C'est donc dans ce café près de
Phoenix que s'organise une forme
de résistance : républicains,
indépendants et démocrates
se mobilisent.
"Les barbares sont à la porte,
dit-il, il est temps d'agir."
"J'étais un républicain jusqu'au
6 janvier, dit ce pilote de
l'armée de l'air. Je fais
maintenant partie des 35 %
d'indépendants en Arizona."
"Ce qui importe maintenant,
c'est de maintenir notre
démocratie, dit-elle,
urur qu'on puisse débattre
à l'avenir."
C'est donc peut-être le calme
avant la tempête. Pour beaucoup
ici, c'est tout le système
électoral qui est en jeu,
la démocratie elle-même
et on craint le pire pour
les élections présidentielles
de 2024.
Car dorénavant les postes clés
pourraient être détenus par
des élus qui nient les résultats
de 2020, et qui cette fois
pourraie a avoir leur mot à dire
pour 2024.
Ils font donc du porte à porte
auprès d'électeurs républicains,
pour les informer des enjeux,
isis la plupart ont déjà voté.
"Hillary Clinton a dit que
les élections étaient volées,
dit-il tout le monde dit ça,
il ne faut pas en faire
un plat."
Contrôler l'inflation et
la frontière sont ses deux
priorités.
"Ce sera une vague rouge,
prédit-il, les démocrates
n'écoutent que la culture woke,
et ils vont en payer le prix."
Kari Lake devance sa rivale
de 3 points, propulsée à
l'avant-scène grâce au soutien
de Donald Trump, certains
prédisent qu'elle pourrait être
sa colistière en 2024
s'il se présente.